(tribal music)
- Raya and the Last Dragon
tells a story of Raya who is a lone warrior
living in the world of Kumandra.
After being separated from her family
living in a divided world, she takes it
upon herself to unify
all the disparate lands
of Kumandra and bring
the world back together.
Hello everyone.
My name is Carlos López Estrada,
I am one of the two directors
of Raya and the Last Dragon.
- Hi everyone, my name Fawn Veerasunthorn.
I'm the Head of Story on
Raya and the Last Dragon.
The scene you're about to see
after the whole action
packed scene earlier,
we just wanted to single
in on Raya's relationship
with her dad.
- [Carlos] The purpose of
the scene is to introduce us
to the world of Kumandra,
to show us that there's
five different lands
and that they are
perceived as enemy lands.
And then Benja very cleverly uses the soup
as a tool to explain
to her that even though
the lands are separate, they shouldn't be.
- [Fawn] In the first shot
we use a lot of the technique
of the frame within frame for this film.
And that was inspired
from our research trip
where we go through Southeast Asia.
A lot of the places we've been
there's a lot of the use of long corridors,
and anywhere you look or take photos
there's a frame within the frame
and the top of each of
these building structures
you see the principle of
using repetition in design,
and that is the very
principle of Southeast Asian
temple design that we kind of adapt.
And in the next shot,
you'll see a little bit
of the fantasy animal to make sure
that you clock that this
is not a real world.
And in this shot we want
to show the daily life
in Southeast Asia.
And every morning you
go and you do something
to pay respects to the invisible world.
- We decided to add this like cloth wipe
transition just to make
it a little bit snappier.
I think we probably saw like
10 versions of this animation
just 'cause we like to explore things
until we're out of time.
And then we landed on
a very simple solution,
but it felt it right.
You know what I was just thinking Fawn?
If we could go back and do over,
I would probably add like a
little bit of a focus shift.
You know, the background could
have been a little blurry
and then we do like a
shift to define them.
Next time.
I think we specifically liked here the,
the contrast between Benja and Raya,
you see him like walking all proper
hands behind his back
and then Raya comes in
just like kicking and
screaming and rolling around.
And it just very clearly
shows the two characters.
I would like to point out that Fawn
was one of the key
promoters of making Benja
look so attractive.
- And Adele Lim.
Can't leave her out of that.
- Adele Lim, the New York
Times wrote a whole article
featuring Benja, Benja's hotness.
So thank you Fawn and Adele.
- I'm glad you feel prepared dew drop,
because I have something
important to tell you.
- If you ever zoom into
their fabric pattern.
What we found is that in Southeast Asia
if there's specific flowers or animals
that's really common in that area,
it will show up in what they wear.
Heart is about water and the
relationship with the dragon.
And if you look at Raya's cape,
at the bottom there's
an image of rain drop.
- Even if you look here at the handrail
and the figure that is
repeated throughout,
it's a water drop and
there's a lot of that motif
throughout all of Heart.
- Tell me what you know
about the other lands.
- First, Tail.
- [Carlos] For this little sequence,
everything has outlines.
The colors are rendered a lot flatter.
It gave us this really interesting look
that we liked just whenever
Raya went into her fantasies.
And you can see this
where we're talking about
like the land identities.
If you look at the first one this is Tail,
it's at the very, very edge of Kumandra.
It's an arid landscape.
They live off of the land
and their colors are warm
and yellow and earthy toned.
So you get to see it very clearly here.
Fawn, anything that you
want to say about Talon?
- I just wanna point out how,
if you ever walk the night
market anywhere in Asia,
this is the exact vibe you'll get.
And I thought it would
be awesome to put durian
in here even though to
throw durian in the air
and cut it like this, it's
probably not that realistic,
but hey, I don't know when
else I will see durian
in a Disney movie.
- Durian is this incredible
fruit from the region
that is specific for many reasons,
but one of them is the
incredibly strong smell.
- Yeah, and we thought that it's important
that Dang Hai is not like, "Ugh it smells."
He's like, "Yes, smells good."
- Spine.
- So, this is land of Spine.
Spine is up north in the mountains.
Spine has the fame of being
this home of warrior community
and they're formidable and
they have like a squinty face.
Like I'm gonna destroy you kind of look,
the last of our lands is Fang.
As you can tell all the geometry is sharp,
they got insane looking battle cats.
So we here introduce them
as like the ultimate baddy.
And that shows you really sort
of like one of the main ideas
in the movie, which is that
we really shouldn't be making
assumptions of people
based on where they live.
Also, there's a hidden Mickey
in this little Fang bit.
So, if you want to pause
it somewhere in there,
you may or may not find the silhouette
of Mickey Mouse hidden somewhere in here.
I'm not gonna tell you where it is,
'cause then that defeats the purpose.
- Okay, so we're gonna
need some cross bows,
and catapults and oh, what
about flaming catapults?
- [Fawn] We always had this passion
to put food in this film and
I took a Thai cooking class.
And I remember the chef
at the time was saying
that like Southeast Asian cooking
is just about putting things that on paper
they don't go well together.
Like bitter, salty, sweet, you
know, all those five flavors.
But somehow when they come together
that is reflective of
this region's lifestyle,
like people coming from different places.
And it's such a perfect way to
state the theme of the movie.
- I was trying to convince Fawn
that we should eat some soup
while we did this interview today.
And she kindly passed on the idea.
- We were once unified,
harmoniously as one.
- We were thinking of this scene,
sort of as our Simba and Mufasa moment
at the top of the Lion King,
where Mufasa sort of like states
the big idea of the movie.
And even though he's not
around for the rest of it
like the philosophy resonates
so strongly in Simba
that it's essentially what drives him.
And this scene played like
a very similar function.
- [Fawn] When I see this
shot, I'm reminded of like
anytime that we talk
about Kumandra and harmony
and togetherness, like the
use of the bokeh effects.
- Yeah, yeah.
Long lenses with like
beautiful blurry background.
And you see all the bokeh lights,
just like really, really
dreamy and aspirational.
So to wrap things up,
I would say that it's
also a good opportunity
to talk about our our set extension
and matte painting, which is you know,
very nerdy animation terms.
But so a set extension is just everything
that goes or like beyond what's built.
In this particular shot,
Raya and Benja are obviously
CG characters that are
fully three dimensional.
The building that they're in is also CG
and fully three dimensional.
And then everything beyond that,
like the mountain range,
the river, the sky,
is painted flatly and these
are called matte paintings.
And then it's all composited together.
I've only been around Disney
Animation for a little bit,
but they tell us that this
scene utilizes set extension
and matte painting
techniques that have never
been done before, at
least in Disney Animation.
Just because the level of detail
and the scope of our world
was so, so huge that there's
so many matte paintings.
And as a button, I will just say,
just imagine how much
cooler it would've been
if we had been eating soup
throughout this whole thing, Fawn.
Next time.
- You're right, Carlos.
Next time we'll be eating on camera.